hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well another
embodiment prima facie duties which WD
Ross talks about in his great work the
right and the goods chapter 2 that is
duties that are incumbent upon us for
the most part in most situations that we
intuitively sense to be our duties is
what he calls beneficence and from the
very beginning he makes clear that he's
not talking about something which was
very close to this which has been a
balance and the reason why he
differentiates these is because one has
to do with an attitude or a set of
intentions and the what the other one
has to do with actually doing things
actually attempting actually following
through this is coming from Latin terms
focker a means to do to put in to act
and bouldering means to will to intend
to wish so it's not enough for Ross that
we want good things to happen other
people or want to do good for other
people rather it's a matter of the duty
being for us to actually do it and it
doesn't mean that we have to be doing
good all the time or in every single
circumstance
what he says is that this is a general
duty which we owe to all human beings or
perhaps even to other beings when we
look at the criteria that he has for
this now it could have more specific
more particular import depending on
relationships so for example I think
Ross would be willing to say that I have
not only a general duty to to all
humanity to be to be beneficent to them
but particularly to those who are close
to me those who I am in day-to-day
contact with for example my wife my
children my other family perhaps less
than than my wife and children my
students you know my students as opposed
to just anybody who emails me out of the
blue perhaps I have a greater duty to
improve their situations than I do you
know just to anybody whatsoever where
does this Duty come from what does it
arise from Ross says that it arises from
the very fact that there are beings
whose conditions we can make better
that's what beneficence means to
actually make the conditions of life of
existence of work of play of study
better for some other beings not only
ourselves but but for them and it's it's
closely related to another duty that I
talked about in another court cuts of
video the duty of self-improvement Ross
conceives of us as having the kind of
you know reflexive relation to ourselves
as we do to other people if i can make
somebody else's situation better I want
to do so if if I can make my own
situation better in respect to virtue or
knowledge or intellectual development I
ought to do so as well for Ross he notes
that not only should we make other
people's situations been
in relation to moral virtue or
intelligence but also in terms of
pleasure so if I can smile at somebody
and it doesn't cost me anything to do so
I Ross would be willing to say it's not
really that big of a thing but I'm
actually fulfilling a duty of
beneficence by doing so and you know you
never really know what your beneficence
actions effects are going to be your
sort of throwing it out there Casting
your bread upon the waters usual proverb
and seeing what happens because of it
your duty is not to actually make it
have a good effect your duty is to do it
Ross and say so you know let's think
about each of these in turn then what
would this entail so making people's
lives better in terms of pleasure
there's lots of ways we can bring people
pleasure some of them in immediate ways
some of them in what we might call
primitive ways when we take away pain
and then that produces a pleasure or we
you know remove the conditions that are
preventing them from feeling some sort
of pleasure some might be instrumental
where we provide them with the means to
have pleasure so if I for example shoot
these videos and you actually you know
let's put aside intellectual development
or moral virtue i'm not trying to let's
say i'm not making you a better person
i'm not making you better inform you
just like watching philosophy videos for
some reason then i am providing you with
pleasure and i'm doing so by giving you
a tool which you can use then to get
pleasure i'm not doing it directly i'm
doing it through some sort of medium and
we can think about money that way we
could think of creating opportunities
for people that way you know more direct
forms of pleasure would be say the
comedian up on stage or the actor
actress who's who's doing something or
musician or the person giving another
person massage or if they're into it
reciting a poem for them you know
there's all different ways in which we
could we could think about this cooking
nice meal for somebody then there's many
indirect ways like I said you know if
you're in pain and I help to alleviate
your pain I am improving your condition
with respect to pain and pleasure and
that would be a form of beneficence so
we could we could run through all sorts
of types of examples of this if I did
that this might get to be a very very
long video so let's let's not do that
intelligence how do we improve each
other's situation with respect to
intelligence this is one where it could
actually conflict with pleasure to a
certain extent by informing each other
we are improving each other situation
with respect to intelligence of course
that assumes that the information that
we're giving is actually informative and
not you know misleading you know if all
I do is cut and paste news articles from
unreliable sources it's very difficult
to say that I would be fulfilling a duty
to to make other people better informed
as a matter of fact I may be going
against that duty if the information
sources are particularly bad I'm you
know unreliable less credible full of
bias but if I'm actually doing work to
help people learn to acquire information
to figure out what to do with that
information understand the information
giving them the skills that they need to
sift good good data out from from bad
data or you know all these sorts of
things teaching them how to interpret
how to argue we're thereby improving
somebody else's condition with respect
to their intellectual abilities so you
might understand the teaching profession
itself has one particular way of
fulfilling the duty of beneficence
journalism when journalism actually does
what it's supposed to do to inform not
just to try to form opinion or something
like that would also be carrying out
this duty there's a lot of ways we could
think about this if for example I
I see that that my my child or my friend
or somebody else has some cognitive bias
and i called it to their attention i'm
actually doing them a good thing now
that's probably going to be unpleasant
for them they're probably not going to
want to hear that because you know once
we have a particular way of seeing
things we tend to take pleasure in that
and we tend to take we tend to be pained
by people saying no no actually that's
not right so this could be a case where
the duty of beneficence has to be kind
of way to have a duty to promote
pleasure or do I have a duty to a
greater duty to promote intellectual
development being in touch with what's
actually real what's actually the case
same thing could be said about moral
virtue here Ross actually engages in
some some interesting reflection and
this is in respect to cut primarily
although you could also think of this in
terms of you know being connected with
with people like mill who are concerned
about paternalism Mills actually two
minds when it comes to that and the
question is whether I can in fact
improve another person's condition with
respect to morality with respect to
moral virtue or whether that has to be
left totally up to them and you could
say well look I can I can give them the
tools and then it you know they have to
decide what they want to do with it I
can I can give them the theory and then
they have to do the practice and kind of
thinks that that's about as far as you
can go if you try to coerce somebody
into becoming a better person he thinks
that you're not actually making them a
better person you're just giving them
motives like you know avoiding
punishment or obtaining reward which are
not really moral motives Ross disagrees
Ross says that yet we do have to be kind
of careful with this it's not so simple
as just legislating everyone shall act
in this way and then expecting people to
act
way I and Ross would be particularly
receptive to Martin Luther King's dictum
that you know the law can't actually
make a man love me but the upside of
that is it can keep him from killing me
it can keep him from taking my my
property the war has some some you know
moralizing effect we can say and
personal relationships have an even
greater moralizing effect if you know if
I have a problem with anger if I have a
vicious disposition with respect to
anger and people come up to me and they
say you know you really need to get your
anger under control and I'm not just
informing you I'm actually telling you
i'm not going to hang out with you if
you keep acting like a jerk whenever you
get angry they're bringing moral suasion
to bear on me to try to improve my
situation in terms of moral virtue Ross
would say that they're actually doing
the right thing in that case if I see
that my my son or my daughter is having
trouble standing up to bullying do I
have an obligation to try to help them
work their way through that so that they
can develop the virtue of courage and
not fall into you know vices of
cowardice or rashness fool hardiness you
know on the one hand or the other Ross
would say I do in fact have a duty to do
so and in fact that would be you know
one where the the duty to beneficence is
more specific based on on the
relationship so each of these is a way
in which we can make other beings
position better now it's interesting
that Ross says other beings he doesn't
say human beings he doesn't say persons
he says beings so what about animals
what about pets in particular do I have
a duty of beneficence to try to give
pleasure
to the animal world Ross would say
perhaps yes certainly if you've taken on
an animal and made it your own and you
are now responsible for it if it's what
we call your pet and if that animal is
capable of you know appreciating a
greater range of pleasure then you
actually do in fact oh it to them if
your dog enjoys going for walks and you
could take your dog out for a walk but
you prefer to play video games all day
and while the dog just lays around loss
would say you're actually going against
your duty to beneficence perhaps not as
much as you know letting down a human
being but it is still doing something
wrong in this situation by by inaction
by choosing other things when you could
in fact benefit them now there's a lot
of questions that would be likely to
come up with how in fact you apply this
and you got to remember that Ross is
saying these are general duties that we
can recognize as applying in a wide
range of cases but they may not actually
be the most applicable ones in every
single case how far it is my duty to
Benefis ins extend if it interferes with
other duties say a fidelity or of
justice or of self-improvement or even
more importantly of non Maleficent's
then this Duty can be abrogated you know
for example let's think of an example
where we contravene justice i can
allocate resources in such a way as to
make a person that that I'm involved
with very very happy but I may in fact
have an obligation to to assign
resources to distribute them in a way
that's fair and by making this person
particularly
which is a good thing happiness is a
good thing I would be getting short
shrift to the other people and thereby
being unfair them in that case Ross
would say justice Trump's beneficence if
I made a promise to somebody say to pay
back a loan and I've got the money and I
could give that money to somebody else
and it would make them very very happy
because they could you know by whatever
it is that they like I still have a duty
to repay the other person first Ross
would say and if if you don't get that
Ross and say there's there's something
kind of off in your you're thinking
you're not really a fully developed
moral agent with respect to working out
these these sorts of intuitions so the
duty to pin to magnificent in part
because it is such a general duty is
often going to find itself being trumped
by other duties that are either in
general more stringent or in the
particular case are more stringent but
it's still a duty nonetheless even
though it often finds itself going lower
in the list of priorities